I think we've done fairly well actually
on Turing, Enigma - all this kind of
thing. We've raced around Bletchley Park-
saw the Colossus machine - which was for
the Tunny, or Lorenz, cipher. There is
a bit missing in the middle:
"Why was Colossus necessary why did they
need a computer?"
What was the nature of that traffic that Colossus
could help with? In one of our previous videos we've
actually shown a picture of this weird
trace that they were getting off the
airwaves. They showed it to the experts
at Bletchley Park and they said: "That's
broadcast teleprinter traffic!" And we've
got to remind ourselves [that] they may not have had
electronic computers back in the 1940s,
early on, but they certainly did have
teleprinter machines. They were very
common - used in stock exchanges; used for
foreign telegrams all sorts.
It looks a bit like a keyboard. As you
press the keys there was a very
comforting 'splash splash splash' sound of
the electromechanical things. Because, as
well as sending five-, or maybe even seven-hole,
pulses over the land-line, it was
also printing out, as you went, what it
was you were typing. So, that technology
was just phenomenally well known. The
staff at Bletchley Park were comforted, in
a way, that it was teleprinter traffic,
but puzzled as to its precise nature.
However, they'd all been on cryptography
training courses - or even
been instructors on cryptography
training courses - and one of the stories
was:  "Don't forget the Vernam Cipher!" So,
again, in a previous video, there's more
details about this but a guy called Vernam,
who worked for Bell Labs, AT&T, in the
late '20s / early 30s, had this idea of
taking 5-hole teleprinter codes and
exclusive-ORing them with an arbitrary
letter, which was like a cipher key, and
coming out with a different letter. I'll
just do one for you just to remind you
of the sort of principles
that went on.[Looks at open booklet front page]
Probably available somewhere online: "Code-breaking with the
Colossus Computer". In the teleprinter code
the letter H is represented by 0 0 1 0 1
Now if you take the letter F, that is 1 0 1 1 0
and from numerous videos we've
done about the nature of bitwise
exclusive-OR it's now dead easy. Exclusive-OR
says you do it bitwise. It is like an
addition but what happens is the result
is 1 if and only if the two bits differ.
If they're the same then the answer is 0
So 0 exclusive-ORd with  1 ?
They're different that's a 1.
0 with 0 ?
they're the same [so] it's a 0
1 with 1 ?
They're the same; it's answer is a 0
0 with 1 is 1.   1 with 0 is 1
The result, then, of exclusive ORing F with H
is to give you
a cipher result of 1 0 0 1 1. You'd have
known this off by heart if you were at
Bletchley Park in the middle '40s, but I
*don't* know it off by heart(!) But the answer
is that it's the letter B.
Vernam said: "That's a great idea! if I provide
a paper tape with a key on it, that's
random, I'll just, y'know, randomize them
myself. I'll type in a great long random
key stream. If you exclusive-OR these
5-bit patterns with each other, and the
other tape is the plaintext, top secret
message, you want to send, then fine! That's a
superb way of encrypting it, you see".
Believe it or not, Vernam and Bell Labs
actually patented this. But there's one
huge problem in getting it to work,
because their idea was you have a 5 hole
paper tape full of your plaintext - your
secret text you want to send - you have a
Gilbert-Vernam-produced equivalent tape
with lots of random [key] and you just want to
run them side-by-side through some
machine that reads that one; reads that
one, exclusive-ORs them and prints out
the encrypted result. And what's the
problem if you
literally use two paper tapes?
Keeping them in sync!
They had huge difficulties with
differential slippage. So you either
ended up with them not in line and not
working at all, or the wrong pattern being
XORd with the wrong pattern. So
in the end the feeling, I think was, among
the cryptographic community: "This is a
promising technique but there's no way
you want to be trying to synchronize two
stretchy bits of tape!" One bit of tape - fine.
You can even keep track.
So there was a knowledge in the cipher
world that sooner or later somebody
would produce the key stream, not on
another tape, but automatically, as part
of the teleprinter process. You could
have a bolt-on accessory to a
teleprinter that provided the 5-bit key
stream automatically, either
electronically or electromechanically.
And so this one that has become so
famous, which the Allies at Bletchley called
"Tunny" -  part of these 'Fishy Ciphers'. They
didn't know what machine was producing
it. And our colleague Jack Copeland,
historian and who's on top of all these
things says: "Every time you mention
this you must mention that at Bletchley
Park, if you called it 'Lorenz' in 1941
they wouldn't have known what you were
talking about!" The company that made the
machine - that did this traffic - was a
mystery to them. They just called it
Tunny. It wasn't just the mystery Tunny
machine there were other machines around.
I have to emphasize this. There was a
Hagelin cipher machine in Sweden,
there was a Siemens cipher machine.
A lot of people were investigating this idea
of providing the keystream
electromechanically and not on a
separate tape. So the overall picture,
then, of exclusive-ORing teletype
characters - the plaintext one with a
key character and doing it character by
character by character by character.
You could summarize it by saying that the
ciphertext
that you prepare is a result of taking a
plaintext - and remember the + in a
circle means exclusive-OR. So that's
your basic equation: cipher text (C) is plain
text (P) exclusive-ORd, character-by-
character, with the key stream (K) like that.
Now we did a thing called "ZigZag
Decryption", which you can look up and you
can see the details of that. To cut a long
story short the Allies were very lucky
in that, by using this special ZigZag decryption,
on a rather weak [and duplicated] message. They
got a whole bunch of Key out of it and
this was like gold dust. In the so-called
Research Section at Bletchley
- headed up by a guy called Gerry Morgan -
[they] picked on a new recruit called Bill
Tutte. He was from Cambridge, just like
Turing. But I empathize with Bill Tutte
because he started off doing chemistry!
And had it been today he'd [possibly!] have moved
into computer science. But as it was then
he gradually turned himself into a
mathematician. He loved doing puzzles; he
went through his Bletchley pre-training
learnt all about Vernam's - and whatever.
And they put him working on another cog
machine called the Hagelin machine which
was used for Italian ciphers. It turned
out to be rather simpler than Tunny
and it was good training for him. They'd
got tons of stuff from this mystery [Lorenz]
machine which was defying analysis. Bill
Tutte was given the chance to make a name
for himself by having a go at it. The
only extra information that Gerry Morgan
gave him was the following. He said: Do
you know the Germans - just like we
encountered on the Enigma in the very
early days - are actually sending us the
initial [cog-wheel] settings. Before we got these
4000 characters the Germans sent out
what we are calling 'the Indicator' "
And it's passed into fame and infamy - the Indicator
[Looks at HQIBPEXEZMUG indicator from the Tiltman Break]
I always pronounce it to myself as "H quib pexxy zeemug"
What you'll find in the literature is people
don't want to say it!
It's called "Zedmug", or "Zeemug", whichever
side of the Atlantic
you're on  and with my mid-Atlantic persona
please forgive me for switching from one
to the other - just like that. So "Zeemug" / "Zedmug"
was the indicator setting at which
they had this lucky [Tiltman] break and could get
the key. Morgan said to Bill Tutte, he said:
"You know, the weird thing is we've looked
at these settings, they're always alphabetic
and if we're assuming that it's a bit
like the Hagelin, and if  there's lots of teeth on
there and all this kind of stuff,
they're only ever using [in the Indicator]
25 letters. Except in one of these positions
[DFB: I can't remember which it was now, I think it's
the fifth one along] In that position
there's only ever 23 alphabetic letters!
We've saved up all the indicators we've
ever had, and on that position they only
use 23 letters out of 26" So, with his
training in mind, Bill Tutte said: "23 is a
prime number.
Interesting! I wonder if - a bit like the
Hagelin machine - this thing is actually
using cog wheels on each of the
bitstreams? Five parallel bitstreams of
a five-bit character. Perhaps it's using
different wheels on different streams
and messing about, that way, with the
patterns of 1s and 0s that gets
exclusive-ORd, you know, as part of the
key generation exclusive-OR thing?
I wonder if this is a cogs machine? If there's a
23-toothed wheel somewhere? But then the rest are
25, right? 23 times 25 is 575. Yeah! let's
start investigating. Now I think, at this
stage, before we get stuck into what
Bill Tutte did, we need to talk about
possibilities of repetitions, depending
on the number of cog wheels you've got.
Let me put it to you like this. Suppose
you have two very simple cog wheels indeed.
So simple they'd never ever be
used in cryptography - but in some sense
these things are on a common spindle,
like that, and every time that [i.e. a cog] rotates it
moves on one position. In fact I'll use a
red pen. I'm saying that this first wheel
has only got two possible positions it
can either be there, or it can be there.
There's a rod, if you like, flipping from
being upright there to upright down
there. Thi one - the fact that it looks
like a Mercedes Benz logo is purely
coincidental - this one has got three
possible positions. Let's call these two
positions, on the two-toothed wheel, a and b
those are the two possible positions.
On the car logo - whatever that brand is -
I don't know - let's just call it 1, 2 and 3.
The start position we can characterize
as being a 1. Then we click the spindle
and it moves on to the next stop
position. a will turn into pointing
downwards and being b The 1 on the
other hand, on the other one, will just
go to 2. So you get a1, b2. One more click.
b will go back to a but 2 will go to 3 - [hence] a3.
One more click - you'll go from a to b
again, but the 3 will go back to 1. b will
go back to a again. 1 will go to 2.
a will go back to b again. 2 will go to
3 and finally back to a1.
It may not look relevant, but it is. This is looking
for repeats. When does a pattern repeat?
And it depends on the number of teeth on
the wheel. So one looks at this and you
think, all right, a1. How long before it
comes back to being a1? [Counting patterns]  1 2 3 4 5 6
Oh! what a coincidence! We've got a
two-position wheel we've got a three-position
wheel. 3 times 2 is 6. It's easy! Instant
mathematics! It's obviously the case
that all you do is multiply the number
of teeth together? Nope?! Even Sean
is shaking his head - not quite.
>> Sean: causation and correlation ?
>> DFB: causation and correlation, yes.
Those of you who are Numberphile
fans this is trivial stuff. You'll know it
off backwards but for those who are less
familiar let's just now develop it one
stage further and be the devil's
advocate. But this time we'll turn
the "motorized" logo into being a cross
shape. It's a four-position cog here and
I'll number it 1, 2, 3, 4.
Now, since I've done this earlier I'll write
out the sequence for you, as to what
happens here. It goes a1 b2 on to a3 on to
b4 and back to a1. So, what's the repeat
length? Fouur. But look - there's 4 on that there's
2 on that, it ought to be 8. Why isn't
it 8? Why is it only 4? And the
answer is there are factors in common:
This [wheel] is 2 that [wheel] is 4.
Four is not a prime number.
It's 2 times 2 so the factor of 2
is -- it's a common base, like doing Lowest
Common Denominators [Least Common Multiples],
y'know, when you're combining fractions you try and
find out what's the thing on the bottom [line]
that's got everything in it, but is as
small as possible. And that is what is
happening here. You don't want cog-wheels
with factors in common because otherwise
your repeat length will be a lot shorter
than you ever imagined. Finally, I'll just
draw out the possibility for you. We'll do
a 3 with a 4. And they now got a b c 1 2
3 4. What is the overall length of the
repeat cycle? And the answer is it's 12
and you say 4 times 3 is 12. But 4 isn't
a prime number! So why is it working out
OK again that you do just multiply them?
The answer is that 3 and 4 are what's
called 'relatively prime'. Although 4 isn't
a prime number it doesn't have any
factors in common with 3. So therefore
relatively prime - sometimes called
co-prime. The story will go, then, on the
numbers of teeth on these wheels, we
think, in this machine, they'll either be
a prime number, or if they ran out of
prime numbers and the prime
number of teeth was getting a bit big, the
next best thing - because it is safe - is to
use relatively prime numbers.
And in the long run we will find
in this [Lorenz] thing we're going to talk about,
that one of the cogs has got 26 teeth on it,
which is not prime but it's 2 times
13. So - so long as that has no factors in
common with anything else that's equally
safe. So this, then, was the backdrop of
what they were expecting - what Bill Tutte
was expecting - it was that there would be
a machine probably with several cogs in
it of some sort and the prime numbers of
teeth would probably be involved. So,
remembering what Gerry Morgan had said
to him about this - that one of these
positions had only got 23
possible alphabetic characters all the
rest had 25 - he said OK what about the
product of 23 by 25? There aren't any
factors in common, you see, 23 is prime.
"Tell you what I'll do", he said "rather than
worrying about the whole character let me
just look at the leftmost stream of
bits in all these characters". Now, I would
call that bitstream 1. What they did at
Bletchley Park was they called it 'impulse 1'.
What I'm talking about is the stream
of bits from all of the characters, like
y'know, the bit that's in the number one
position over all characters in the
message, from one to five, left to right.
He started off with what he regarded as
bitstream 1, the leftmost one.
He said: "remembering my training which
said if you think there's going to be
repeats have a look for them?" And he said:
"Well, why not do two at once? If I do 23
times 25 I might be able to spot
vertical runs happening every 23, if I
write them out in a block. I might see
them at 25 because they're not going to
interfere, they're relatively prime. So, on an
enormous sheet of paper and it doesn't matter
whether it's Turing, Bill Tutte  or a host of
other workers at Bletchley Park, they
used acres of big sheets of paper,
divided up into squares, to make notes on.
And he said:
"I wrote it out along a great long strip;
575 bits then another 575 then another 575.
And, don't forget. this intercept was 4000 characters.
So, he ended up with six and a half huge
long rows - all on this combined period of 575.
And he said I was expecting to
look down vertically and find every
23 there was a bunch of 1s
or something like this, or every 25.
He didn't see that looked at it
carefully and "... to my amazement" he said [as
you look at it] I saw, going down these
five rows, a clear diagonal sequence of
1s, going like that but down the
diagonal! What did that tell me? I'd got
the wrong period it wasn't 575, it was 574".
41 is a [prime] factor of 574.
So, as he says in his paper, if people say
this genius Bill Tutte was straight on
to spotting 23 and 25
and it was the first thing he found ... No, he
didn't! He went off down the wrong trail
temporarily but accidentally, with sheer
pure luck, found that the number 1 stream
was having its 1s and 0s
that were added to it [and] was generated by a
wheel, probably, with a periodicity of 41.
But the Germans wouldn't be daft enough
to make sure there's a blindingly
obvious repeat every 41. There'll
be 'messing about' going on behind the
scenes. It will be 41 but it will
perhaps be disguised. But maybe they
didn't totally succeed in disguising it enough.
Armed with 41 what he then did
[he] said right I'm gonna write down all of
these sequences now, not on a 575
grid but on a grid of 41. So he
writes out this impulse stream of 1s
and 0s but the tradition at Bletchley
was to use '.' for 0 and 'x' for 1.
Tutte says he can't understand why they did this.
Other people say " ...  it's all very
well, Bill, for you mathematicians, wanting
1s and 0s but I find patterns
easier to spot with dots and crosses".
I think I agree, actually. And when he put
out all these impulses - all 4,000 [per stream] of them -
on a grid 41 across, you suddenly find
that - not on every row but on quite a few
of them - there are certain patterns that
repeat. So the message from that is 'Yes,
there is a wheel with 41 teeth involved
but there's almost certainly
some extra stage where it's trying to
disguise what's going on. That might be
another wheel with different teeth or
something's going on. It's not pure and
simple. It wouldn't be - because it'd be
dead easy to decrypt if it was. But there
is a sneaky suspicion 41 was involved.
So, Bill Tutte tells the rest of the
Research Section who piled in and helped. Because
what he points out - the next obvious thing to
do is look at the number 2 stream, look
at the number 3 stream look at
number 4 stream, look at the number five
stream. And when we've worked out what
the initial wheels - how many teeth
they've got on - then we can take that
away and start looking to see if we can
figure out how the excess stuff, that's
trying to distort it, gets generated. And
to cut a very long story very short,
after a few weeks work of probably 10
or 11 people, what they finally came
up with was in this diagram here. They
decided that initially your stream from
your teleprinter was put through 5
distinct cogs, one for each bitstream or 'impulse'.
The numbers of teeth were 41, 31, 29, 26, 23
So, as Tutte says, " ... eventually
if I'd not discovered the 41, I
would have proved what a genius I was
because 23 *is* there. It's just that it's
on stream 5, not stream 1. But it is
there, right! And then they managed to
discover that the obscuring mechanism
was another set of wheels which
sometimes turned on by one place and
sometimes didn't.
And these have got 43 47 51 53 and 59
teeth. And the eagle-eyed among you who
watch every single morsel of Numberphile
will immediately jump on our necks and
say 26 isn't prime. No - it isn't. It's 2
times 13 but it's relatively prime to
everything else. Equally 51 isn't prime,
it's 3 times 17. Fine. So, if you use other
"relative prime-nesses" you can't have
2s or 3s involved in their factors
because they're taken up now. But that
was it. These two extra wheels at the
bottom? There was another thing: they
could sort of understand why 10 wheels -
two sets of of 5. Well what do the
other two do? The other two - in a very
complicated way - determine whether this
second set of wheels moves or stays
still. And I think the Germans were
hoping that by that mechanism they would
confuse the Allied decryption effort
even more. Because the first set always
move. You do a character-worth it'll click
and they [the cogs] all move on. But they've
got different numbers of teeth on them.
[The] second set sometimes moves, sometimes
doesn't. By the end of the war the
feeling was from people like Jack Good
and Donald Michie, who had a look at this
statistically. They said: you know by the
time you got used to looking for whether
the wheels were moving - a 'stutter' we call
it - you got to be able to 'spot the
stutter' and it was such a landmark, once
you were really familiar with it, that
the Germans actually did themselves a
disfavour. They'd have been better off not
to put it in. They managed to get all of
that structure out of it. What they
realized was their next big task was to
say: OK - we know the number of teeth on
each wheel but what we don't know is the
patterns on the wheels of 1s and
0s that they are contributing to the
exclusive-OR key characters. So, that was
another great long journey because they
knew that, on the Hagelin machine, so
it's probably similar on the
Tunny machine, that on every cog there
was a little slider which could set up
or down. And in one position it
contributed a 0, but if you put it
down it always contributed a 1. So, can
you imagine going ... the task of
setting this wretched thing up! You've
got all of these cogs with all these
teeth and if you add up the total number of
teeth of several hundred. And every one
of these positions has got to be set up
with a 1 or a 0, according to this
instruction manual. Do you think they
changed them every day? Not a chance!
They [initially] only changed the wheel patterns
once a month.
You've got the Indicator that tells you what the
[initial] wheel settings are. You can work
for a whole month on trying to work out
what the wheel patterns are. Once you've
got it you can decrypt like mad. What
would happen if they ever stopped [started] saying:
Let's not put the indicator out. It only
helps them. [Actually] it doesn't help them, it's
totally secure. But it's pointless to put
it out. Just like on Enigma. So, in the
middle of - early to middle of - 1942 they
stopped putting out the Indicator.
Oh dear! Calamity.